uns weiterhin zugeschaltet also selenski
ganz klar man darf sich da auf keinen
Kompromiss einlassen gleichzeitig heute
in der Nacht einer der größten
gefangenenaustausche diese Operation
diese Organisation des ganzen er lief
vermutlich schon zu dem Zeitpunkt als
ihr auch miteinander gesprochen habt
nimm uns einmal mit was genau ist da
passiert wir sehen hier beispielsweise
führende Kämpfer Soldaten ukrainische
Soldaten aus dem Asus Stahlwerk dort in
Mario Pohl wo sich zuletzt ja wochenlang
Zivilisten und Soldaten verschanzt haben
eine aussichtslose Situation damals
diese Männer die kommen jetzt frei
genauso ist es Patricia viele von diesen
Männern kommen frei die kommandierenden
so ist das geplant sollen in der Türkei
bleiben bis der Krieg zu Ende ist
offenbar hat Erdogan dort eine
entscheidende Rolle mitgespielt bei
diesen Verhandlungen aber für silensky
ist das natürlich auch hier zu Hause ein
großer Erfolg und man hat ihm das dort
gestern bei dem Interview angemerkt ich
glaube dass du dem Zeitpunkt als wir
dieses Interview geführt haben ist schon
klar war dass dieser Austausch
erfolgreich sein würde das erklärt auch
so ein bisschen seine gute Laune in dem
Interview und die vielen Witze die er
dort gemacht hat bzw dass viele lachen
was man dort wahrnehmen konnte und ich
habe
silenski in diesem Interview gefragt ob
er als ehemaliger Komiker ein
Lieblingswitz hat über Wladimir Putin
hören wir da einmal rein
in ihren früheren Leben herr Präsident
sie waren ein ja Komiker haben sie ein
Lieblingswitz über Putin
[Musik]
ich denke ja
ich bin nicht sicher dass ich bereit bin
diesen Witz hier zu erzählen
ich bin nicht sicher ich denke sie
werden lachen und in Russland werden
Menschen weinen ich bin nicht sicher
dass das angebracht ist
sie können das schon sagen
es ist ein schwarzer Humor
er mag ihn dann doch nicht erzählen Paul
diesen Witz ich habe einen Moment
gestockt als ich das gesehen habe deine
eurem Interview erscheint ihr Scherz
dabei der lacht in diesen Zeiten
gleichzeitig was irgendwie tröstlicher
Moment
absolut geil ist das erste Mal dass ich
selenski wieder so gesehen habe ich habe
ihn mehrfach interviewt seit
Kriegsbeginn und es ist das erste Mal
dass sie auch wieder so ein bisschen der
alte silence aufblitzte also dieses
schelmische Lachen das witzeln das was
sie noch ausgemacht hat eben bevor der
große Krieg hier begann und ich glaube
das ist auch notwendig selbst wenn
Präsidenten dass er zumindest mal ein
paar Sekunden man wenige Minuten
abschalten kann und ich glaube in diesen
Räumen auch wenn das vor der Kamera
nicht machen wollte da gab es schon
viele Witze über Vladimir Putin
[Musik]